أجنبية
أجنبية وبالطبع الولايات المتحدة فخورة
بأن تكون رائدة
[موسيقى]
أجنبية
أه شكرا جزيلا لك صديقي العزيز
توني أه توني بلينكين وزير الخارجية
في الواقع هذه أه العلاقة هذه
الشراكة تعود إلى شوط
طويل أه إلى المشترك  العمل ضد داعش
وبناء نهاية المسيرة السياسية
للعراق
[موسيقى]
واشنطن
وجودنا هنا في واشنطن هو
لإجراء الحوار والمناقشات
مع الولايات المتحدة
تحت قيادة
الوفد الأمريكي برئاسة وزير الخارجية
الموقر توني بلينكن وأشكر  له على هذه
الدعوة ونأمل أن تكون مخرجات هذا
الحوار خدمة لمصالح
البلدين والشعبين
[موسيقى]
وأه أسس هذا الحوار
هي المبادئ الأساسية التي
ورد ذكرها
العملية المشتركة الاحترام المتبادل.
التأسيس في مختلف
أه المجالات
العسكرية والأمنية والتجارة الاقتصادية
والطاقة في جميع مجالاتها المختلفة
طاقة نظيفة
غاز وقود كهربائي
وكذلك المجال الصحي ومواجهة جائحة الطمع 19 جائحة والعمل والتعاون في مجال التعليم [الموسيقى] وبجهود وتعاون القوات العراقية بكافة فروعها ودعم الشعب العراقي والتعاون. من التحالف الدولي ، تمكنا من هزيمة ما يسمى بالدولة الإسلامية التي هي داعش واستئصالها من وجودها ، لكن التنظيم الإرهابي يظل منظمة إرهابية وكتنظيم عسكري يعتمد على أيديولوجية معينة [موسيقى] نشاطات [موسيقى] [موسيقى] لداعش في العراق قبل أيام كانت هناك عملية انتحارية أه في المدينة الجنوبية نتج عنها أه استشهاد عدد من المواطنين فضلا عن عدد أكبر من الجرحى بين المواطنين فهل هؤلاء أه أنشطة داعش أه مستمرة ما زالت موجودة وتمثل خطرا على المجتمع العراقي على المجتمع الإقليمي وعلى المجتمع الدولي [تطبيق]  ause
] ولأن التنظيم الإرهابي
هو
تنظيم محلي نشط داخل العراق
ولكنه أيضًا منظمة إقليمية ودولية
تعتمد على أيديولوجية
تنظيمية دولية تتطلب عملاً
دوليًا وتعاونًا دوليًا
ولذا نحتاج إلى التعاون مع
التحالف الدولي و  للعمل مع
التحالف الدولي
بقيادة الولايات المتحدة
ضد داعش وتبادل المعلومات
مع
التحالف الدولي والولايات المتحدة
والعراق لهزيمة
داعش.
علاقاتنا مع الولايات المتحدة
ليست مجرد علاقات عسكرية ولكنها
واسعة.  وعلاقات واسعة وفي
المستقبل سيكون لدينا
تعاون أوسع بكثير في جميع
المجالات التي تم
ذكرها ، وتعتمد الحوارات الاستراتيجية
وتعتمد على دفع
هذه الجهود إلى الأمام لتحسين حياة
الناس وتحسين مستقبل العراق
، ونشكر المتحدون.  الدول
للمساعدة والدعم أنا  الرق ومجلس
الأمن للحصول على قرار بالإجماع لدعم
العراق وإرسال مراقبين
لرصد الجهود الانتخابية
التي تعتبر مهمة للغاية
لمستقبل العراق ومستقبل شعب العراق
والديمقراطية في العراق
في النهاية ، الله في النهاية أكرر شكري.
إلى
صديقي وزميلي العزيز الوزير توني
بلينكين
لاستقبالنا ونتوقع
إجراء مناقشات عميقة من شأنها أن تقودنا إلى
نتائج مثمرة
لمصلحة البلدين.